what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder and Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios might
have to switch some things up with their
Phase 5 and Phase 6 release schedule
unfortunately we knew that this would
most likely happen with Bob Iger coming
back in replacing Bob chapek we knew
that there were going to be some changes
specifically in regards to Disney plus
however this isn't exactly a bad thing
because Bob Iger is coming in and he is
focusing on quality not quantity which
after reading a lot of comments in one
of my recent videos talking about how
Kevin feige wasn't exactly pleased with
phase four neither was Bob Iger it
sounds like a lot of fans were kind of
feeling the same and agreed that the
quality wasn't exactly there for all of
the projects so some changes are coming
that are hopefully going to address this
issue and fix it and from what we've
heard so far it sounds like that's
exactly what they're going to do
unfortunately that means a shift in the
schedules which we'll talk about in just
a bit we are also going to be talking
about Dr Doom and his possible MCU debut
it might be sooner than you think
however it could be a very bad thing it
could be a bad idea to introduce him at
this time and we'll talk about that in
this video also the Marvel Legends
giveaway is happening we'll pick a first
winner this weekend so be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment Down Below
in each video to enter the winner will
be picked at random and announced in a
video so as I mentioned if you caught my
recent video about Kevin feige not happy
with phase four you knew that this was
probably coming and I did say that there
was probably good and bad news and that
is apparently what we have today we have
some good news and we have some bad news
and we'll start with the bad news it
looks like phase five and phase six are
going to be a lot longer than we thought
they were not because there's going to
be more projects but because the
schedule is going to be moving
essentially the release dates for a lot
of projects are going to be delayed so
essentially instead of Phase 5 and phase
six lasting about three years from the
beginning of 2023 to about the end of
2025 it's looking like Marvel Studios is
going to stretch that out a bit more and
make it last till 2026. hopefully not
longer than that now this report today
is coming from Alex P over at the cosmic
circus and he says in regards to
anything being canceled nothing's
canceled yet but that slight moving like
and it showed a gift of Beyonce saying
everything to the left basically meaning
we're going to be expecting some delays
not cancellations and that's the good
news nothing is actually going to be
canceled so if you were excited for a
Marvel project during phase five or six
still be excited for that in fact you
should be even more excited because this
shift actually means they're going to
put more focus on each project and give
it more time which means the quality of
each project should be better and he
actually goes on to talk about how that
is indeed a good thing he says while the
Slate moving means having to wait longer
for future projects to be released it's
ultimately for the sake of keeping
quality over quantity I'll just say this
don't expect 2022 schedule of at least
one Marvel project each month to stay
true for 2023 2024 so again don't panic
this is an entirely bad news yes we
might have to wait a little bit longer
to get to the Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars and whatever film or show you're
really excited to watch but hopefully
that weight is going to pay off by the
show or the movie being better and I'm
all for this I definitely think that
Marvel and really well Disney was
focused a little bit more on quantity
and getting their Disney plus
subscribers up than they were the
quality of the content and rumors have
suggested that that's what Disney was
about at that time that Bob chapek
really wanted to boost subscribers for
Disney plus so he had Marvel and Star
Wars and other franchises pump out
content so it probably wasn't even
really Marvel studios's fault I'm sure
Kevin feige wanted to slow down a bit
but Disney said hey we gotta pump up
this content we gotta pump out these
shows and movies but Bob Iger coming
back he's saying slow it down let's
focus on quality which is an amazing
thing so expect a slight delay in this
schedule but I think it'll be worth it
in the end now Dr Doom we all want Dr
Doom in the MCU and I think a lot of us
were pretty disappointed when we didn't
see him show up in wakanda Forever
however luckily this was always kind of
just a rumor and I don't think a lot of
people had expected him to show up too
much yes there have been reports that he
was possibly removed from a deleted
scene but that doesn't really matter now
what matters now is the very important
question of should Dr Doom be introduced
in the MCU at this point in time and I'm
asking you this because I truly want to
know your thoughts so please leave them
in the comments down below after I
mentioned this recent rumor leak let me
know what you think here's what it says
Dr Doom is in the Thunderbolts and not
in an insignificant way or credit Cameo
he's in a movie in a featured role as
the leader of latviria which is where
the climax of the film will take place
he's not the villain of the film or even
a Villain at all he's presented more
like t'challa in Civil War than anything
else but the Fallout from the climax of
The Thunderbolts particularly the
actions of Red Hulk will lead him being
thrust into the MCU in a major way now
first things first this is coming from
4chan so take that with a grain of salt
it is in no way confirmed to be true
it's just a rumor and although this
rumor is very intriguing and I think
would excite a lot of people I still
find myself asking the question if this
is the right move there's a lot coming
in Phase five and phase six a lot of new
characters getting introduced and even
the Fantastic Four are getting
introduced as well so I can see how a
lot of people would turn their heads to
Doctor Doom however hear me out here's
what I'm concerned about I'm concerned
about Dr Doom becoming Ultron a one
movie villain and then being done with I
do not want that to happen and it seems
like Marvel Studios isn't really doing
that anymore the infinity Saga while we
did get villains like Loki and Ultron
who a lot of people said were pretty
wasted did eventually an Avengers
Infinity war and end game give us Thanos
for two movies in a big significant way
that is what Marvel Studios is planning
on doing for King the Conqueror as well
we get him in the Kang Dynasty and then
in secret Wars actually to take it even
further we really got him at first and
Loki we're probably going to get him
again in Loki season 2 and we know we're
about to get him an Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania so it seems like Marvel
Studios for these really big movies and
specifically The Avengers movies aren't
really wasting villains they are trying
to really do the most they can with
these villains and not just have them in
one film and then be done with them
there's even rumors that Ultron could be
coming back at some point in time but
that's a video for another day so that
leads me to my question do we actually
think it would be a good idea to
introduce Dr Doom at this point in time
because Phase 5 and phase six are
already pretty crowded I would hate to
see Dr Doom appear and then disappear
and yes I know what some people are
thinking well perhaps they could do the
secret Wars storyline from the comics
where Dr Doom takes the power of the
beyonder and creates battle world and
yes I would love that however I think it
would be a little bit too rushed and if
you try to introduce another big bad at
the same time as Kang who was the big
bad currently it might get a little
messy and take the focus off of Kang
which I don't think should happen Dr
Doom is such an iconic villain arguably
the most iconic villain to come from
Marvel he deserves his own Saga and he
doesn't deserve to share it and Kang
doesn't deserve to share a saga either
which is why I think Marvel Studios
should wait to introduce Dr Doom until
the next Saga or simply just hint at him
that he exists and then tackled the true
story in the next Saga but in this
recent rumor it states that he is going
to be simply a character in Liberia not
a good guy not a bad guy but it does say
that the events of the Thunderbolts are
going to lead to doctor Doom's story in
the MCU in a pretty big way which I
think would be a mistake I don't think
we should dive into Doctor Doom until
the next Saga because he can be a
villain to the mutants and the Fantastic
Four which I think phase 7 is heavily
going to focus on so that's my opinion I
think they should wait but let me know
what you think about this and the
comments down below do you think they
should introduce him now do you like the
idea of him being introduced in the
Thunderbolts or do you think they should
wait let me know down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date with all the recent news
don't forget to follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf